how's it going everybody so big exciting
news today we got some more promotional
art leaks for Avengers for in these
promotional art leaks we get a brand new
look after surviving Avengers in what
appears to be quantum realm suits not
too long ago we got a leak and we saw
Thor and Rocket in these suits it was
widely speculated that these suits were
for traveling inside of the quantum
realm and that all of the Avengers would
in fact have to go inside the quantum
realm well it seems like that is going
to be true for Avengers 4 because these
new leaked concept art photos show all
of the remaining Avengers in these suits
I'm still giving away copies of Infinity
Ward Deadpool 2 and Ant Man and the wasp
on blu-ray as well as some special
edition posters if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
as you can see here we have Ironman
Captain America Thor Hawkeye ant-man
rocket nebula The Hulk and Black Widow
the only person that appears to be
missing is war machine
boom are you looking why do I even talk
to you guys everywhere else that story
kills though perhaps he can't go inside
of the quantum realm because of his legs
so we obviously don't know all of the
details but clearly somehow ant-man
winds up with the surviving Avengers
after Thanos a snap whether that's
through a time vortex or time travel in
itself we don't know but clearly somehow
he gets back to them and him and Tony
and possibly Bruce Banner developed this
quantum around technology because what's
really interesting is that if we take a
look at Iron Man we can see that he is
not entirely wearing his traditional
Iron Man suit he still has the helmets
and you can still see the blasters in
his hands but he clearly needs the
quantum suit over or in replacement of
his Iron Man suit because of the dangers
that are inside of the quantum realm if
you remember what dr. Hank Pym said to
Scott Lang in the first ant-man movie he
said this is not some cute technology
like the Iron Man suit this could change
the texture of reality so we know that
his Iron Man suit isn't enough to keep
him protected inside of the quantum
realm and again these are concept art
photos they're usually just photoshopped
they take a pass picture and they
Photoshop it into this new picture
that's most likely the case with a few
of these if not almost all of them if
you take a look at Black Widow you can
see that her head is clearly not that
proportionate to her body that's because
it's just taken from a different picture
and put on this picture for toy
companies and in fact if you look at
Rocket Raccoon he's in the exact same
pose that he is in with the promotional
toy art that we saw with him and Thor
it's the exact same picture the only one
that looks relatively new is the Hulk's
face this doesn't seem to be taken from
anywhere else that I can remember but
what's really cool about it is that it
does really seem like it's Banner and
the Hulk now which means we're probably
getting professor Hulk in Avengers for
the most interesting thing about these
photos are these little devices on their
left hands the first leaks that we got
for Avengers 4 were of Iron Man Ant Man
and Captain America during the events of
the Battle of New York and on each of
their left hands they were wearing these
small circular devices much like we see
in these photos and if you take a look
at that first leaked photo they're not
wearing these new quantum realm suits so
perhaps these new quantum realm suits
are some sort of nanotechnology and
these circular devices are housing units
for the Nano parts these could also be
how they phase in and out ant-man has
the buttons on his gloves but they're
built into his suit that is meant for
shrinking so instead of just building
them into everybody else's suit they
make ones that are detachable these
devices are most likely one of these two
things and they could even be both of
these things somehow but they're clearly
going to play some important part with
the quantum realm and with time travel
in Avengers 4 so everything is sort of
connecting now the very first leak that
we got for Avengers 4 showed the
Avengers wearing these devices on their
hands and we know that they were back in
time they were in New York during the
Battle of New York from the first
Avengers movie and now the most recent
leaks show The Avengers wearing these
devices and the quantum realm has been
severely emphasized over the past few
months so everything is sort of tying
together now we're going to get more and
more information The Closer that we get
to Avengers 4 hitting theaters and with
each new leak more connections will be
made but what do you all think about
these brand new leaks for Avengers 4 let
me know what you all think about these
brand new suits and the devices on their
hands and the comments down below and
don't forget to subscribe comment down
below and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything related to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]
you